YouTube is quick to play your content if
it's controversial if you're dealing
with something that's unsavory YouTube's
not going to pair their big media buys
against it you'll probably get flagged
at which point you're not really going
to be getting the prime real estate for
ad revenue you're not encouraged to make
a piece that has issues like murder or
rape or hell even a love scene because
these things are controversial and ads
don't pair with controversy so those TV
shows that you enjoy the shows that deal
with not only the good sides of humanity
but also the dark and evil sides shows
like Game of Thrones house of cards
orange is the new black Breaking Bad
stories that can delve into these topics
are honestly what in my mind
differentiates things like movies and TV
shows from YouTube so a few weeks ago
YouTube announced YouTube red which is
basically a subscription-based side of
YouTube for $9.99 a month you are
getting no ads on YouTube background
audio playing on your phone so you can
use it to listen to music and access to
original content there is one other
facet as well when you watch someone's
video part of your subscription money is
going to go to that person who made that
video in other words people who you
enjoy watching actually get increased a
revenue from your subscription so you're
having more of a direct influence on the
artists that you enjoy now I'm not here
to make a judgement on how much it
should cost or anything like that
instead I want to point out an
interesting thought if you like the kind
of content that you see on Netflix or in
a film or on HBO hopefully something
like YouTube read with its subscription
service offering freedom from ads will
encourage some of that kind of content
to get made as well what you get through
this process is a piece that is much
more focused on telling stories house of
cards isn't interested in selling you on
products and aside from the occasional
product placement of course
generally speaking house cards is trying
to convince you to watch it because it's
trying to be a good story through and
through its trying to be good drama that
draws you in show after show rather than
having to rely on an advertiser to feel
that the story was popular enough to
deserve commercials and commercial money
miller Goods question is how
crowdfunding plays into all this
something like patreon supports that
specific artist and it helps drive
Pacific connection between the audience
member and the creator of content
YouTube read isn't supporting any
specific content creator just like a
cable subscription or an HBO
subscription it's a different draw than
somebody trying to draw you in because
the next video is hopefully going to be
really funny or hopefully going to have
something really cool in it hopefully a
service like YouTube red will provide a
way for content creators to go out there
and tell more mature stories and tell
the kind of stories that don't always
pair so well with advertisements so
something to consider as we jump into
the future of YouTube and see where this
subscription model takes us but while
there have been many arguments as to the
downsides of paying for content
hopefully this is something to consider
for an upside as to paying for content
and helping out the content creators
that make the media we enjoy and here's
something that would probably frustrate
people to hear this but the more people
can get in the habit of actually putting
dollars towards the content that they
enjoy consuming the better that content
is going to be you know it's great to
get things for free and there's
certainly been a heyday of getting
things for free online but we can get in
the habit of you know putting a buck
towards somebody that creates content we
like you're going to see a healthy
ecosystem creating that content for a
long time to come that's just the nature
of it you know money does make things
happen so people don't like to talk
about it but it's true